we're here at the Indianapolis couting
combine join us now gentlemen who has
been the general manager of the
Jacksonville Jaguars how many years now
seven eight they kept going on eight I'm
going on
that means you getting all 2013 that
means you get no we're getting old -
yeah Dave Caldwell Dave Jaguar Jaguar
David gentlemen so how you doing I'm
great
great good to be back in Indianapolis
the home of the combine well you were
with the Colts for a while if I wash
yeah migrated to what you went from the
Colts to the Falcons and end of the
Jaguars yep
11 years in India five in Atlanta you
say home in the combine you know it's
not gonna be home to constantly alright
but it's not gonna be the movers and
shakers the people who are paid to make
the big decisions are gonna yank at the
ally is that does that disappoint you at
what disappointment III like it here I
think this is a I think logistically
it's good for all teams yes right it's
equitable except for the Colts get a
little bit of home-field advantage
yeah but I probably know more of the
inner workings of it living here and in
terms of the locations of the hospitals
and the stadium and the surfaces that we
run on and everything so sometimes
change isn't always better
yeah I agree this city is great for this
because it's we all can walk everywhere
nobody's gonna get in cars and do stuff
like that you don't have to go outside
no you're right you can go underneath
the tunnels or the sky walks or whatever
are you a fan of the reorganization of
the combine you know just yeah kind of
tell us what how it affects your life
yeah I actually I'm anxious to see how
it works out I've always had a hard time
focusing at the interviews at night
after dinner and from 7:00 until 11
o'clock at night you're sitting there in
a room and bam bam bam you got 15
interviews and 20 minutes apiece so I
think I'm gonna like the workouts at
night better yeah and being able to hey
if I need to get up and grab a cup of
coffee or coke or whatever right I can
do that yeah you saw coach Miran walking
around earlier I think you hit his
Bologna
he lost weights he did he looks great it
looks great
can't get over I think yeah I think
coach Moroni is he's getting ready for
OTAs and minicam he's wearing some
shorts like Gardner Minshew
I don't want to see him and George
no you had something in Shu when was the
moment the mommy six round draft pick I
mean you didn't know at the time right
you know during OTAs we felt like he was
really grasping things quickly and and
as decision-making was really good and
then we get into the preseason and he's
playing with you know we didn't play
many starters and appreciated enough at
all
and he had some ups and downs and then
it really we weren't able to sustain
some drives but if you look at what he
did himself individually and said well
if you put him around some players he
might be okay and then after he
completed 22 straight passes and Kansas
City I think we might be okay here right
and for him to do that and that opening
game was pretty impressive so how do you
balance this going forward I mean what's
the thought of the organization right
now with foals and gardeners well I
think the thought is a competition is
gonna be great I think to have two
players there at that position that you
know let's not forget what Nick has done
in his career and Nick is a tremendous
competitor and a tremendous player and
won a Super Bowl and his body of work
you know is very impressive and I think
we got new offensive coordinator new
quarterback coach and maybe I'll just
defer it to them and say you guys figure
out how but no I think you know it was
unfortunate Nick went down but they'll
be able to come in and and have a guy
come in and now you feel good about a
geiger Manchu and what he can do yeah
when you look back on the 2019 season
and one thing that stands out the
decision to trade Jalen Ramsay something
that I don't think you guys really
wanted to do but you got to a point he
had no other choice when you reflect on
it is there anything that could have
been done differently to kind of get him
to change his mind and stay well I'm
sure you know when when you go through
situations like that that those are
organizational decisions of when you
trade him and and and what you have to
get for him but you know I think I said
her last year you asked me if I was
going to trade Jalen Ramsay and I said
no I'm not in the business of training
the best player at the position so I
never thought that I would it came to
that at
and but we felt like if we were gonna do
it we needed to get something special
for it because it's a special player in
a special talent and and sure enough we
felt like it was probably not one of the
best trades in recent history the
best-trained yeah
I mean two ones in a four is a lot to
say no to we went through that whole
analysis at the time like how many
players out there would you say if you
got the offer of two ones and a four get
out of here we're not giving you the
player for that that's a lot especially
a positional player you can make a case
for quarterbacks but an actual
positional player and then what can you
turn those picks into can you turn them
into six pictures yeah whatever I'm
writing something
well what so we're in this new era of
like higher empowerment oh they're
playing like you know they're playing GM
game now here a little bit and you know
owner game they're playing business how
does that change your approach well I
think our approach is a statement and it
comes to this it if those things happen
it's gonna be on our terms - yeah
and with the Jalen situation it just so
happened that if we did not get the
value we got for him he could very well
still be a Jaguar so it wasn't like we
were just gonna give him oh I know you
weren't I know you weren't so I think
for us it becomes a you know we have
these players that are empowered based
off of the CBA they have their rules or
they have our rules but I think the the
biggest thing is is that it has to work
for us
in order to do it if not we're gonna
have to keep the player and he may be
disgruntled he may not be happy about at
the end of the day he starts to come to
work if he wants to play football so
you're just more willing to kind of
swallow that it out because like I look
at Yannick and gawk way right Yannick
and gawk well you got a tough decision
to make you you know he's he's really
good you want to pay him I know you
drafted them you hit gold there but also
I guess you got to be a little worried
about putting the franchise tag - and
just maybe the issues that players seem
to share kind of draw a line as well and
there is that and and I think you know
knowing our owner and and our
organization is he'll draw stand in line
- you know so you try to do what's best
for the team obviously first and then
what's best for the player and and in
this case is that you know the player
has rights
you know team is right so we didn't
negotiate the at least I didn't
negotiate the rules or trans franchise
tag or to transition tag and all that
stuff so so we'll use everything in our
power to keep you out of here and
and hopefully it's in a long-term deal
if it's not it would be for a year on a
franchise tag and then if the new CBA
has a second franchise tag you know
we'll address that when that time comes
but we think the world of them yeah how
do you feel about playing two home games
in London this year well I'm gonna get
my fill of fish and chips for sure and
but it'll be a challenge and I'm up for
the challenge is it better what this
don't you have an advantage you're
playing two games back to back to home
games the second game you guys are
settled in you're ensconced you're ready
to go
whereas you know the team you're playing
the second week is still adjusting to
being in lung and they'll help our first
week too because historically when we
got in there we've had to do a lot of
community stuff on that Friday or
Saturday a lot of rallies and stuff like
that so we're gonna push all that back
until the players day off on Tuesday so
I'll help us you know going out there in
that first week and then on that second
week and the normal players stay off
Monday night or Tuesday they'll be able
to do a lot of community stuff and we'll
be able to do even better and bigger for
the fans in London the biggest challenge
I think will come to be what does our
schedule look around those two games
right and how far are we how long are we
gonna be away from home no ones are
going to be our home game before London
because if you have a home game before
London that's three home games in a row
if you have a home game after London
that's four you know so it's gonna be
interesting how the schedule comes out
with that well last year we both picked
you guys to win the division yeah so
this year we won't we won't jinx you out
of the game let's go back to 17 because
you pride and pick us in 17 all the best
congratulations eight years and Counting
in Jacksonville and we look forward to
talking preciate thanks very spork ask a
lot mountains
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports